[Music]
[Applause]
and we're back
we're back thank you everyone
kendall royce stole my haircut
oh he did yeah he did does anyone see my
[ __ ] kids
[Music]
his kids grew up like
six years yeah in two seasons did they
not yeah
wasn't that kid like a toddler when
logan hit him i thought
wasn't he he was like four
is that what he did logan hit his kid
logan hit the kid yeah what episode was
that like
three or something super early in the
first season why did he hate him
uh because it was thanksgiving and the
kid was like oh it was the uh the game
that they were playing like uh i bring
this to an island and the next person
has to bring that plus one other thing
and it's like a memory game and logan
was like still recovering from a stroke
and he like couldn't
remember and the kid was like i forget
what it was but the kid like took
something from him or something and he
was like it's mine
the can yeah which designates whose turn
it is
and he's like i'm still thinking he like
nailed the kid in the face [ __ ] power
move no i'm kidding
i'm kidding
totally
and that's just that's his character
yeah that's a logan move right there
just slapping a child um
you know you thought kendall was gonna
get some kind of
something yeah then his dad hit him with
the
that that rye smile before he's like
how long was he underwater oh god
how long was he under that he started
sucking water ugh
i think that's what the he was doing at
the end of the episode right yeah yeah
counting it out
uh oh what is that what he was doing i
think that's what it was uh i see he's
like seeing
damn i didn't even think of that no so i
thought i thought he was just straight
up drowning
nah
because he drops the beer bottle and so
i was like oh man is it
he wasn't in the preview for the next
episode
so maybe
i mean
what's so funny is the best quote is
that
he's not playing it like a comedy he's
playing it like it's hamlet
and he's concerned that people think
this show is a comic
it's a [ __ ] comedy
yeah dude
i don't [ __ ] produce by will ferrell
is it not
it's hilarious how can you say that
before the ep the episode where romans
has a dick pic to his own dad yeah
clearly it's a [ __ ] comedy yeah
that whole scene
[ __ ] dude yeah
yeah someone screenshotted just his
faces and they were like he deserves an
emmy just for these yeah and it's so
true that face that he makes he realizes
his mistake and he's like
he's so good when he looks at his dad
just like
tough moment to sell dude tough moment
man are you a sicko yeah are you a sicko
roman
are you a sicko what
he just sent him it's like here's my
dick you know then when he [ __ ] stan
that line
i'm not like a hardcore feminist or
anything but i don't think we should
fire jerry for receiving
pictures of my dick
damn
you know it's all about yeah the ship
shiv has been
oh man she's getting it she's shifting
it up she's just
twisted
that was crazy the wink wink she was
doing with jerry does this happen more
than once
yeah
but then basically like
putting the blame on her for not
reporting it you know it's like yeah
she's trying to scam her in the wake of
everything that's happening it's like we
you know wouldn't really be smart for
the ceo of this company not to report it
happening to her so you're trying to get
roman out yeah but that's like a [ __ ]
up way to do it
hmm
hilarious um that
roman botches his whole
trajectory
with a picture of his penis i know
how fitting yeah
he's a sicko are you a sicko you're a
sicko
do you have a problem
no dad have you heard a dick pic dude
and he was like we invented a media
company probably came up with the
[ __ ] phrase that was so good damn
dude you cannot get one over on this guy
yeah you hate him yeah when does logan
roy die yeah
like
people were dude some some dude
i saw some dude at a restaurant the
other day his shirt said [ __ ] live
forever
yeah
the person i was with was like yeah
logan roy look at him that's like true
yeah
because they can't be
they can't um submit
not even to sickness
you know yeah
like logan roy would probably have a
heart attack and still be flipping off
the [ __ ] you know paramedic yeah
don't [ __ ] revive me
he'd probably have a stroke and freeze
his left hand as a middle finger
it's a great episode though
yeah
and greg just trying to level up yep
damn
well look at the time
jesus dude
he's got zero game yeah act like you've
been somewhere yeah it's kind of it's
kind of endearing though yeah and that's
what pulls people in yeah because he
does that goofy [ __ ] and he's like i
heard you're of the uh uh royal
persuasion
pretty disarming i know it early it's
like this guy
serious yeah
is he dumb it's kind of charming yeah
weirdly yeah he's really tall yeah
yeah now that's what it does it just
makes him realize this guy's weird but
he's tall yeah
if if it was inverse
if roman was
greg's height being the way he was he'd
be hated by everyone yeah exactly yeah
and if greg was a little man walking up
through like look at the time
swat him yeah yeah
go away
see that tweet that i was like watch out
short kings yeah there's one on both
sides
i saw hawk flying around so many people
send me that [ __ ] you i can fight off a
[ __ ] hawk dude
i wear the coyote vest too okay
so yeah i guess the whole thing about
this is that he's a method actor
oh jeremy strong yes gotta play kendra
and he like puts himself through hell to
play this character like he's like
actually this tortured well he's nailing
it yeah he really is
and it's funny because this quote he's
not playing it like a comedy he's
playing it like he's hamlet totally
plays into his character yeah who would
never realize that people are laughing
at him no that must be brutal for the
whole time he's filming this [ __ ] he's
in kindle mode
yeah
and what if he just like wakes up in the
morning is like chirping at people yeah
like do things for him
like he wants that no just like it's his
family like his girlfriend and like
is that his actual wife yeah oh where
the [ __ ] are we at where the [ __ ] are
you
honey
you're at home
there's snap out of it this please
one day
when i asked brian cox who plays logan
unbelievable name by the way yeah of
course brian cox
who plays logan the patriarch to
describe strong's process he struck a
note of fatherly concern the result that
jeremy gets is always pretty tremendous
i just worried about what he does to
himself i worry about the crisis he puts
himself through in order to prepare cox
a classically trained british stage
actor has a turn it on turn it off
approach to acting his relationship with
strong recalls a famous story about
lawrence oliver working with dustin
hoffman
the 1976 film marathon man
i learned that hoffman had stayed up
partying for three nights before a scene
which he had
had to appear sleep deprived oliver said
my dear boy why don't you try acting
cox told me actors are funny creatures
i've worked with intense actors before
it's a particularly american disease i
think
i think this inability to separate
yourself off while you're doing the job
damn huh
wow way to own americans in the process
there strong had me tech had sent me
text messages from italy including a
poem by cecil day-lewis and thoughts on
the invisible work of acting since i'd
seen him in new york he had shaved his
head twice once as kindle and once as
himself
on his phone he showed me photos of jack
dorsey the co-founder of twitter both
clean-shaven and with a raspy teen beard
strong response kendall that's rasput
rasputin
your canadian just came out
right
rasputin
they say rasputin like you came out
poutine yeah you just saw putin and you
were like poutine can you pronounce it
both ways i thought it was rasputin
rasputin lover of the russian queen she
was a cat that really was on
yeah that's bony m isn't it
i heard that song like once
that's a there's like an edm remix of it
now that's huge yeah
anyways a strong thought that that
kendall should go through a similar
physical evolution
he said citing the third line of dante's
inferno oh my god a straight road had
uh been lost sight of
no one strong included wanted a cliched
scene of kendall staring into the mirror
with a razor so the transformation took
place off camera nevertheless no stylish
shade his head strong went silent to
experience the moment as part of
kendall's backstory
after the season wrapped he shaved his
head again as an exorcism
yeah he is kendall he really is this is
crazy what the [ __ ] dude
shut up kendall i gotta hear i gotta
read this yeah yeah he kept doing this
speech that he had sort of written
culkin said all i remember is him saying
root and tootin a lot by the third take
he starts that speech again and snook
looks at him as shiv and goes shut up
kendall
he must be a [ __ ] monster on set
can't even imagine you have to go into
character when he pulls up it's like oh
here we go oh god here we go yeah
yeah it's like the cameras aren't even
rolling yet yeah everyone's saying roman
what's up
no dude
i'm i'm not doing i'm not too tired for
this yeah he's pulling the character out
of you that's kind of good though yeah
yeah i like when people do that between
yeah i don't i just like makes it
i don't know when they run lines and you
like actually get into character yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
shut up kendall